[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback senior NFL reporter joining
us on the program the Cowboys make the
right decision
yesterday uh I mean I think I think they
probably did and I know it's not going
to satisfy very many people but you know
I think there are two things to look at
if for with Jerry Jones here like first
this is to his history I mean it's just
the idea that he's like this wild cat
owner is just wrong um you know he kept
Jason Garrett for nine and a half years
he got into a fourth year with Wade
Phillips um you know he really has never
had a quick trigger and he has been
loyal to his coaches and he's empowered
his coaches and so you know I think that
that's that that that's one piece of it
and then the second piece of it to me is
I maybe a little fear um you know they
won 12 games three years in a row it's
been a long time since the Cowboys were
that good over an extended period of
time and I know the playoff um results
haven't been satisfying but I think you
know it's maybe a little fear that if we
pull the plug on on what we've got now
um and try to hit reset and even with
the same group of players it might be
hard to to to get up to this level again
and look like there's gonna be Fallout
too like now I mean I would say Dan
Quint probably leaves right like
especially with the opportunity in SE
Seattle out there you know if they offer
him the job I think he'd have a hard
time passing it down um and then you
know this could mean bich going to
Atlanta so there's certainly some T
tentacles that that come off Jerry's
decision after meeting with Mike
yesterday do you think the Cowboys ever
reached out to
belich I mean I wouldn't be surprised
Jerry and Stephen have a very good
relationship with Bill you know so it
would certainly be a lever they could
pull if they wanted to um and I look
like he doesn't work for the Patriots
anymore so you know it's you know
certainly something they could do and if
you remember like one the last time that
Jerry fired a coach like like Jason was
sort of twisting in the win there for a
while like they were borderline running
a search while Jason was still employed
you know so um it certainly wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't go against you know it
certainly it wouldn't be unprecedented
when it comes to the way Jerry operates
and he has a sort of relationship with
bich where if he wanted to do it he
could certainly do it you you see belich
and the Falcons as a uh a good
matchup yeah I do um you know I think
there's a there's a couple elements here
like first there there are some
connections um between Arthur Blank and
and Bill and um you know like they they
they had Thomas demitros there uh for
for 12 years 13 years I think actually
um and like Scot heel was there for a
time so you know Arthur Blank has seen
the Patriot vernacular and it's actually
worked for him in the past and that's
given him a way of back channeling to
bellich over the last few weeks um you
know and then I think the other piece of
it like that you know I like I I just
think it's like a different type of hire
than blank's ever made before like if
you look back at his 25 years zoner um
you know he had Jim Mo Rising young
assistant probably vetrino college coach
Mike Smith like a experienced assistant
but never seen as a head coach that
worked out pretty well and then Dan
Quinn Arthur Smith is rising young
assistant so um this would be totally
different but he's you know he's 81
years old and I think he's thinks he's
got a team that's right on the precipice
if they can get the quarterback position
worked out to compete in the here and
now and so it would make sense if he
would act with urgency right now which I
think is part of why he you know fired
Arthur Smith as quickly as he did and
why they moved to go and bring belich in
as quick as they did I I think a lot of
is going to come down similar to like
Harbaugh with the Chargers I think a lot
of it'll come down to the infrastructure
there and if Bill thinks that he can set
it up the way that he wants to set it up
yeah we talk about Jerry Jones and his
age Arthur Blank has been closer to
winning a Super Bowl than Jerry Jones
has and there's a sense of urgency they
have a young team they just need to have
a little bit more of a culture there it
feels like they've they've you know they
were eight- n eight- n and eight and n
well you're going to pick eighth in the
draft every year and you're just not
going to get that much better and I
understand if you're going to swing
Arthur Blank is swinging for the fences
whether it's Harbaugh or bellich but you
think Harbaugh still more likely if he
goes it's the
chargers there's just so many te Leeves
that are playing that way um you know
Dan I think like if you look at like
with their their their um their general
manager interviews I mean we can break
this down like Joe Ortiz Works in
Baltimore worked with John Harbaugh Ian
Cunningham in Chicago came up in
Baltimore worked with John Harbaugh Ed
dods worked with Jim Harbaugh in Oakland
20 years ago they've got a really strong
relationship um and he's been seen as a
guy who could be Harbaugh's GM for a
while now and then Brandon Brown the
Giants assistant general manager has a
relationship with Harbaugh as well so
that's four general manager H general
manager interviews that have been
connected to Harbaugh um I I just think
like if you look at Jim I I think from
an NFL perspective he's like the modern
day Parcels right like he is gonna come
in he's gonna shake your program up he's
gonna get um he's gonna get results
really really quickly and he's gonna run
hot and so like that might mean you're
not signing up for 10 years you might be
signing up for four or five but you know
what it's going to look like and you're
probably going to get results really
quickly and they've got this sort of
roster where you can say that's exactly
what they need you know like they've got
a roster that's ready to win right now
and the presence of the quarterback
obviously isn't lost on anybody so I
just think for a lot of different
reasons it matches up now I think what
this is going to come down to a lot of
people have made a lot of the money
right the Chargers are sensitive to the
idea that they're Irrelevant in LA or
that they're cheap and hiring Harbaugh
would address both those things I don't
think it's so much paying Harbaugh it's
like are you willing to pay to bring in
all the people that he wants there right
like so does he want to bring Jesse
mener as his defensive coordinator for
Michigan how much is that going to cost
U does he want certain things in their
new facility set up a certain way you
know so there are a lot of things that I
think are important and then I think
from Jim's perspective after how things
you know ended in in in in San Francisco
I think his feel for the Spanos family
is going to be really important too he's
Albert Breer the Monday Morning
Quarterback senior NFL reporter the
eagle situation Nick serani has not met
with his owner they I think supposed to
or at least it's been reported they'll
meet today feels like Diana Rini with
her reporting that they're looking for
coordinators here not looking for a new
head coach is that how you read this so
like I would caution anybody to draw any
sort of conclusions until after that
meeting happens because this is sort of
how it went with Doug three years ago
where like you know like Jeffrey didn't
do his meeting with the coach like the
day after the season he waited and um
and waited almost a week you know and
like that allowed for for Doug and for
Howie to kind of get their ducks in a
row and here's what it's goingon to look
like and you know when when Doug went in
there there were disagreements over the
staff and that wound up being sort of it
you know so like my perception of what
Diana reported yesterday might be a
little different than some other people
in that like I think some other people
said like oh well maybe that's not
exactly that's not that that's not what
you'd be doing if you were getting fired
right I look at it more like okay are
they just getting their ducks in a row
now and put and and working to put
something in front of Jeffrey lury and
then it's up to lury to decide what he
wants to do I think that that's probably
more a more realistic way of looking at
it uh it's a sensitive subject I'll try
to approach it as delicate as possible
How concerned should the NFL be with Jim
mer running the
Colts I mean you know like there's that
thing right like where you say that um
that the owners are held to the same
standard as players and the NFL tried to
trumpet that forever and then you know
after um you know after a few different
things happened they took that language
out of the out out of their bylaws right
or out of their constitution and I mean
I I think they've sort of made it clear
um in doing so and conducting themselves
the way they've conducted themselves
that it's like that old teex Tech Shram
line I don't know if you've heard that
one but at one point like this was like
in the 70s or 80s during one of their
labor
negotiations uh teex sham was the
president of the Cowboys at the time
said you guys don't understand you're
the you're the cattle and we're the
ranchers and I sort of think that's what
this is you know what I mean like it's
just they aren't held to the same
standard because I do think a player
again I do want to be sensitive to it
you know but I think like
if a if this was a player or this was a
coach or this was an executive they
would be like in a situation like this
they would get treatment they be treated
with care but they'd be removed from the
situation right like so you would
immediately move to say okay we're gonna
get people to take over his duties and
we're gonna whoever it is like whether
it's a coach a player or somebody in
office like you know we just can't have
that person in the in you know out front
for our organization anymore and um and
we're going to give them their time time
to get well and I actually think that's
sort of the humane way to do it um but
you know a lot in a lot of these cases
with owners they don't want to go
through the embarrassment of being
removed and they have the power to say
no and so that's what makes you know how
this will be handled going forward a
little less predictable yeah if this was
the NBA the NBA's taken control of
franchises that doesn't happen with the
NFL yeah it doesn't and it's just I mean
look it's like sort of the ethos of the
sport right like and it's just I mean
we've SE I'm I don't need to list the
number of owners but there everybody
knows there are a few where it's very
very clear they're not held to the same
rules that that everybody else in the
league is is it possible Harbaugh
doesn't get an NFL job
offer I mean I'd say unlikely I I I
still think the charger again like I
think I think it's more in this case and
he hasn't gotten I mean it's not like
you know like the Broncos last year was
like real back and forth but other than
that like I like he really hasn't gotten
a hard offer um over the last years I
think it's different this year you think
the Chargers job is his if he wants it
Albert yes okay yes and I think I think
but I think like the context of that's
going to be important right like so I
think a lot of it is going to come down
to um you know how how it looks and how
how things are set up and you know I
think that that that'd be the thing that
Jim would leery of you know I mean look
like there's no secret you know he's
clashed a little with his athletic
director at Michigan and he had an issue
with the owner in in in San Francisco
and the Chargers have not only the owner
but like the the two sons John and a um
run the football side and the business
side and so you know is John comfortable
is Jim comfortable with that like I
think that's the stuff that they really
need to work through so I don't think
it's a question of whether or not he'd
get off of the job I think he will I
think it's the context under which he's
offered the job right like and what are
the rules of engagement when he's going
in I think that that's the important
stuff again I think they'll pay him like
I think they will I think a lot of it's
going to come down to how it's set up
and whether or not he's comfortable with
that always appreciate you taking time
out safe travels thank you Albert all
right thanks Dan appreciate it that's
Albert Breer Monday Morning Quarterback